ce qui me plus frappée c'était la
réponse à volodimir zelensky concernant
l'ambition de l'ukraine d'adhérer à
l'otan parce que l'ambassadeur ukrainien
au royaume uni monsieur prix style qu
avait dit que peut-être que l'ukraine
pourrait accepter
peut-être en tout cas de résinier de
cette ambition mais après tout de suite
il a dit que ces mots avaient été mal
interprétés et un journaliste a donné à
volodimir zelensky l'opportunité de dire
très clairement que l'ambassade du
royaume uni n'avait pas dit que
l'ukraine ne voulait pas rentrer dans
l'otan que c'était absolument la
politique de l'ukraine d'essayer de
rentrer dans l'otan et volodymyr
zelensky a répondu à la question d'une
manière un peu elliptique si on peut
dire il a dit nous aimerions rejoindre
l'otan il a souligné que l'ambition de
rejoindre le temps l'otan est inscrit
dans la constitution ukrainienne mais il
a été clairement beaucoup moins direct
sur ce point il a dit aussi que cela ne
dépend bien sûr pas de nous il y a eu
ensuite la chose qui a dit que la
question de l'entrée de l'ukraine dans
l'otan n'est pas à l'ordre du jour pour
le moment on pense bien que olaf scholz
à moscou demain va revoir va essayer de
convaincre vladimir poutine qu'il n'y a
pas de risque que l'ukraine rentrer dans
l'otan la russie voudrait que ce soit
écrit noir sur blanc qu'il y ait une
garantie que l'ukraine n'entrerait pas
dans l'otan ce que l'otan les états unis
les graines les autres est un membre ont
constamment dit est absolument
impossible mais en sont peut-être une
tentative peut-être en assouplissant un
petit peu la rhétorique on insiste on
pas aussi vds avait pas autant de
véhémence sur cette ambition peut-être
que il pense qu'il ya une chance de
convaincre les russes ou du moins de
continuer le dialogue
l'hiver le président ukrainien en tout
cas a qualifié de grosse erreur la
décision de certains pays occidentaux de
déménager leur ambassade de kiev vers
l'ouest de l'ukraine
oui les ukrainiens sont très mécontentes
toutes ces mesures d'évacuation
d'ambassade aussi le le fait que les
états unis le royaume uni et certains
autres pays je crois vous retirer leurs
membres des missions d'observation du
conflit dans le dos de bath les
entreprises qui demandent à leurs
employés de partir tout cela est vu d'un
très mauvais oeil des ukrainiens à cause
de ses effets sur l'économie ils disent
c'est comme si c'était nous qui étions
maintenant sous la coupe des sanctions
parce que ça porte un coup très dur à
l'économie ukrainienne cette idée que
peut-être les compagnies aériennes
arrêterait de voler ou de survoler
l'ukraine cela a obligé l'état ukrainien
de monter un fonds de garantie de
environ 600 millions de dollars pour
pouvoir garantie ces compagnies heures
aérienne alors que leur assureur avait
dit qu'il ne pouvait plus assurer leur
sécurité tout cela dans un contexte où
l'ukraine clairement oui commence à
penser que la menace d'une agression
militaire par la russie à grande échelle
est réelle et que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument prendre au sérieux
et pour laquelle il faut se préparer
mais dans les scénarios qu'on imagine
scénario où ce serait la capitale qui
seraient bombardées qui seraient ciblés
dans des délais très courte à partir
d'aujourd'hui semblent bien moins
probable est moins bien close il qu'un
scénario d'une escalade d'une base par
exemple et c'est pour ça que volodymyr
zelensky et ses collègues mais son
centre est sont assez fâché je pense de
ce que ces ambassades fonds qui risque
de semer la panique dont la société
ukrainienne et de porter encore plus
atteinte à l'économie